foreign
began one of the most famous novels of
the 20th century with a passage in which
the protagonist bites into a tiny cake
served with tea and it triggers a flood
of childhood memories
and perhaps a more familiar example when
Anton ego is served a plate of
Ratatouille
he is thrown back to a childhood reverie
that proves life-changing
is it that particular events become
etched in our minds seemingly impossible
to forget while so many of us cannot
even remember what we wore yesterday
[Music]
well as we all know intuitively there is
a very powerful link between memory and
emotion
our brains prioritize emotional memories
for encoding and recall
and the more intense the emotion whether
positive or negative the more intense
the memory
foreign
but where in our brain do these memories
exist and how are they stored
what happens when these processes go
awry in either new memories however
emotional The Experience cannot be
formed or the brain goes overboard and
stores every experience
and to what extent do our brains take
creative Liberties crafting deeply
emotional memories of things that never
actually happened
many of the processes that determine how
we encode and retrieve memories remain a
mystery nevertheless the last decade has
witnessed enormous progress
scientists at Columbia University
recently identified a specific neural
circuit that tags information with
emotional associations thereby enhancing
memory at least two other teams the
United States are currently working on
prosthetic devices to boost fading
memories via electronic stimulation and
here in Australia genes once derided as
junk have been shown to play a pivotal
role in regulating fear that research
has even revealed that emotional events
May reshape us down to our very DNA
the same time there's also New Hope for
those experiencing the debilitating
consequences of the most traumatic of
such emotionally evocative events
we will talk to a group of leading
scientists whose research illuminates
these and other vital links between
memory and emotion their work seeks to
reveal how the rich swirl of memory
emotion and self-awareness shapes who we
are as individual human beings
and that's the issue which will serve as
our guide tonight as we take a deep dive
into memory the pathways that make us
human
[Music]
good evening
thank you
so I'm Brian Greene co-founder of the
world Science Festival with Tracy day
and it is our great pleasure to finally
be back here in Brisbane live and in
person last time of course is back in
2019 which of course does strain the
memory with everything that has happened
in between it certainly has been a
traumatic time in many different ways
but
when I consider
my own memories when I try to push
myself to really think back to the
earliest memory that I really can
conjure up in my mind it's the following
it's a bright sunny day I'm in a
stroller my dad is pushing me along and
I'm playing with little beads that are
on a rod right in front of the stroller
my dad pushes us down 81st Street makes
a right turn goes to 82nd and Columbus
in Manhattan to his favorite hot dog
stand
I don't know if you have hot dogs as you
call them you know it's like a little
cylindrical piece of beef right
or they call it beef I I really don't
know what the heck they they they have
in there but anyway so my dad buys
himself a hot dog and he buys me one
usually they come in a piece of bread a
bun but for me a little toddler he gives
it to me in my hand and I take a bite
Crunch and I eat it now as someone who's
been a vegetarian since nine years old
that memory is actually kind of
traumatic thinking back to that
but but here's the thing when I actually
think of that memory I I really I can I
can I can feel the day I can feel the
stroller going down the street hitting
the bumps in the sidewalk I can I can
feel the warmth of the hot dog I can
really taste and smell the crunch but
I'm seeing it in third person I'm
watching myself do that and so it's not
an actual memory or at least it's a
modified memory or a changed memory or
in some sense My Telling of that story
over the years say to my my kids and my
family has somehow transformed the way I
reflect back on an event that actually
did happen but in my mind it now takes a
different form and so that's Central to
the kind of question that we are going
to be investigating and exploring here
tonight how is it that memories are
encoded how
can they be modified how do they stay
stable over long periods of time and
what happens when that stability starts
to drop away and can memories be
volitionally manipulated or modified and
when we get to the point where perhaps
we're able to do that the question is
should we or can we or will we and to
guide us in exploring these questions
tonight we have four wonderful experts
participants who I'd like to bring in
now our first guest is Timothy Brady who
is a professor of cognitive neuro
epigenetics at the Queensland brain
Institute whereas lab studies the
fundamental molecular mechanism
underlying fear related learning and
memory welcome Tim our yes thank you
our next guest is Veronica o'keen who's
a neuroscientist a retired professor of
Psychiatry and a consultant psychiatrist
at Trinity College Dublin with over 30
years experience in the field she's the
author of a sense of self memory the
brain and who we are welcome Veronica
[Applause]
next we have Gail Robinson who is the
director of the clinical neuropsychology
doctoral program at the University of
Queensland she is a clinical
neuropsychologist whose research focuses
in part on brain Behavior relationships
welcome Gail thank you
[Music]
and finally rounding out our group here
tonight is Oliver Bauman who is an
assistant professor in the School of
Psychology at Bond University whose
research focuses on human spatial
perception memory and emotion welcome
Oliver and of course welcome to you all
[Music]
so you all study memory that's that's
your day job or perhaps even beyond your
day job
your own memory I gave one example where
I sort of can push myself back to
probably two-ish something like that
three-ish what do we know how far back
can people typically go and how far back
do each of you go and do you trust those
memories Tim what you started off for
myself I think my some of my first
memories were probably at the age of
three and I can remember one moment
where I I fell off a balcony in the
front of the house into a rose bush
that could have been your last memory
your first and your last I remember the
the Thorns wow yeah and is that why do
you remember the emotion attached to it
so we'll get into that absolutely yeah
so Veronica
um the first memory that I have is
looking down on an orange cardigan that
my mother knit
and remembering the curvature of the
button at the time I was sitting on
something which I later found out was a
box
and because we were moving house so
clearly that made an impact on me I was
about
three again around the same age right
absolutely so Gail how about you well I
think I'm a bit older actually I was
trying to think is there anything before
five and I really just have maybe two
memories of I think I was about five one
we caught the train across from
um Canberra all the way to Perth as a
family and I remember being in the
lounge room of my grandparents place in
Perth we were playing a card game or
some sort of game but I wasn't allowed
to play because I was probably being
naughty
so I just remember being told off for
some reason I don't remember much else
so there was some trauma there too then
right yeah yeah Oliver yeah I'm actually
would have a problem knowing which phone
was the first but I have a couple of
early ones which would be around three
to four years of age including one where
I made my first ever purchase I remember
like I'm buying like a little bag of
stickers in the shop and my mother sent
me in with the coin to buy it myself so
it must have been three or four at that
stage and um yeah that's one of the
early memories
so those are early memories and I think
you know all of us have some variation
on the themes the details differ but we
can usually push ourselves pretty far
back there are many things most things
in fact in our lives we don't
directly remember I mean if you were to
ask me you know what I was doing on
Whatever May 17th of
2006 I'd be very hard-pressed to to give
an answer to that but there are some
dates that that we all do remember for
instance 911 right I mean 911 is one
that you know I don't think there's
anybody who's around at the time that
doesn't have a pretty Sharp vivid memory
of of that day so you know part of it's
obvious right that was a very different
day but can you take us a little bit
further say Tim just to get us going
what is it about that kind of an
experience that leaves such a lasting
impact in our memories I think it's
anything that has a lot of emotion
attached to it and a lot of surprise
that kind of triggers the the Pathways
in the brain to etch those memories for
the long term
right so you know with respect to 911 I
remember exactly where I was where were
you I was in a car driving to the New
York border with my friend from was from
Jordan to get his Visa renewed huh yeah
we didn't we didn't make it to the
border that day wow yeah amazing yeah
and I suspect you didn't cross that
border for a long time yeah be my guest
yeah uh Oliver can't take that any any
further is there something about the
power of emotion that primes the brain
yes so emotion is obviously um an
important currency for the brain to know
when to encode something or not because
encoding a memory is expensive for the
brain
um and therefore emotion surface and as
a signal to you know how much to invest
and you know what memories to prioritize
and how much
um you know effort to put into it and
quote them so therefore you're without
emotion we would unnecessarily encode
information we might not need to and you
know that's a huge cost to the system
but could you imagine and and Veronica
Redding come to a specific example where
you're going to take us through some of
the neurophysiology that actually is
behind this but more fancifully can you
imagine you know so perhaps a life form
maybe even on this planet but let's
imagine an extraterrestrial life form
that is able to form memories in a
selective manner but is not based on
emotion is that a peculiarity of the
human species or do you think that's
sort of a general quality Nature's Way
of having a selection effect on which
memories we should store answer the ones
that have the biggest emotional impact
well I think that it's pretty uh
ubiquitous in nature for a survival
mechanism to have
um a driver like like emotionally
relevant memories or or um intense
memories or typically the ones that are
causing threat or fear in us and that's
absolutely essential for survival right
so it's it's across all species
so given that Veronica can you take us
to you have
some slides where you can lay out to get
a sense of a traumatic experience
yielding a certain kind of emotional
response that generates a memory so you
can take us through this exam sure well
I think the first thing to say in
relation to emotion and memory is uh
that emotion is is energy and that is
the energy that lights up the neurons in
our brain and the energy can be
internally generated or externally
generated and 9 11 was a fantastic
example of
a stimulus that was globally experienced
and that was individually experienced
and that we all remember but we also
remember it in a a collective way so
there is a collective memory
and the collective emotion that's
present what I'm going to talk about is
something that isn't Collective it's
something that we're all familiar with
but thankfully
um at least not in my lifetime and
hopefully not in most of your lives
times will you be ever confronted with
this threat
so uh the threat I'm going to talk about
is a gun being put to your head so what
happens when a gun is put to somebody's
head or something threatening like that
is the light waves from the gone the
image goes to the back of the eye that
of course is a form of energy LightWave
is a form of energy that's converted to
electrical energy and the electrical
energy travels along the neurons to the
back of the brain to the visual cortex
note that the brain is surrounded by the
cortex and the cortex essentially
interprets the sensory World it
interprets the visual world in the back
of the brain the auditory world the
touch world
so all of the senses come to the surface
of the brain and after they
land there and already our visual cortex
knows what a gun looks like because
we've learned it
um as we've developed
and the signal then shoots into the
center of the brain into a place called
the hippocampus the hippocampus is
absolutely Central to memory because
it's the Memory Maker in the brain
so the Memory Maker in the brain is
directly adjacent to a structure called
the amygdala and the amygdala is
um at what I call the emotional spark
plug of the brain
and frequently we speak about the
emotional Center and we speak about the
memory Center but in reality the
physiology is that these two structures
are so densely interconnected and so uh
the the neurons and the dendrites and
the connections between them are almost
inextricable so as you see the gone the
memory is immediately triggering an
emotion in the amygdala
so we've gone from visual sensory to
identifying that two memory two
emotional Center in the brain and this
translates into experiences in the body
into the sense of fear through a
the signals from the emitter going to a
place called the hypothalamus
which is just above the surface of the
brain and the hypothalamus is the
headquarters for the autonomic nervous
system in the body and that mediates the
flight and fight response at an extreme
but also other emotions and that may not
be as extreme it could just perhaps pump
your heart with excitement it could be a
sad image it might make you have a
crushing sensation in your in your chest
so the range of experiences that the
autonomic nervous system
mediates in our body is very variable
and it's a whole range of emotions there
but essentially they're immediate
they're being
manipulated through the hypothalamus and
the autonomic nervous system and I think
it's important in terms of trauma
because we're all interested in trauma
here is that if something very severe is
threatening an individual that this very
same memory system of the hippocampus
and the amygdala and the hypothalamus
activates another system in the body the
endocrine stress system so you have
exactly the same brain circuitry if a
threat is very severe that activates the
stress hormone about 10 or 20 minutes
later depending on the severity of the
threat
and this system is not a nervous system
it goes into the bloodstream and it
carries a hormone from the hypothalamus
to the adrenal glands and in the adrenal
glands the hormone cortisol is released
so you can see here how acutely the body
deals with an immediate stress by
releasing adrenaline and the peripheral
nervous system in the body and then over
time a more sustained response
in terms of cortisol kicks in to keep us
Vigilant to monitor the stress
but presumably that serves an
evolutionary function of survival but
presumably if you have a sustained
release of these hormones it begins to
act against the the being that's the
case as well no absolutely absolutely
there's a thing called allostatic load
which is basically the wear and tear
that stress reeks on the body
and too much cortisol we I I've done a
lot of research in depression and one of
the main areas of research that I've
been involved in in fact is looking at
the effect of cortisol on the brain and
very interestingly in terms of memory
cortisol has specific effects on the
memory Center in the brain
on the hippocampus so if we're severely
stressed over long periods of time and
of course depression is one of the most
extreme forms of mental and emotional
and cognitive stress well you're
actually damaging your memory by being
in a sustained state of depression
absolutely so the hippocampus over time
following chronic exposure to stress
hormone the dendrites the neurons start
to retract the hippocampus actually
shrinks but at the cost of it the
amygdala actually does the opposite so
the emotional Center expands it shows
hypertrophy
so you can see there becomes a shift in
a bias towards strong emotional
responses so at the cost of memory
though but is that sort of a kind of
runaway process it sounds like it'll
feed on itself it would yeah and over
time there's yeah well it's called a
Cascade hypothesis because the more
stress you have
the smaller your hippocampus becomes the
more emotionally driven you become
and this of course creates more stress
which feeds back and further damages the
memory Center
so Oliver just to um go back a bit to
the evolutionary roots of this all back
in 1872 Charles Darwin published uh
somewhat lesser-known volume in in the
general world but certainly a volume
that's well known in the academic world
describing the emergence of emotions as
a quality of of the human species and so
what's our view today on the evolution
evolutionary roots of emotion and the
way that feeds into the formation of
memory yeah I guess you have I think an
important aspect highlighted by Darwin
is that emotions have a function because
when we experience them in day-to-day
life often we feel they're just there to
reward us or punish us and you know we
want more of the good and less of the
bad emotions but obviously they've been
put in place through Evolution to ensure
survivors so that even the simplest form
of animals would probably feel good if
they find a little bit of nutrition and
feel bad if there's like
bit of water that's too hot or too cold
and so from the simplest forms of
animals to the highest forms emotions
have evolved to guide us to the good
things that you know allow us to prosper
survive and grow and then keep us away
from the bad things and and our brain
has involved in humans of course
compared to simple animals but still the
same mechanisms that emotions are simply
there to protect us and to guide us and
that then also via the memories
now Gail we we were talking so far about
memories if it's a single thing right I
mean there's so many at least from an
intuitive standpoint different kinds of
memory right you know I I know how to
drive to our house in the country I
don't even think about it but somehow my
memory takes me there I'm speaking right
now I'm not trying to draw up the words
by searching in my memory but somehow
it's happening right and yet there are
other memories when we talk about them
where they're really there in a more
definite form as opposed to something
that's in the background so you can take
us through the different kinds of memory
and and perhaps even give us a sense of
how does the brain decide which kind of
memory mechanism to use yes so there are
different memories we always
um I guess when people talk about my
memory is not so good really they're
talking about episodic memory and our
episodic memory is really our memory for
ongoing events so where was I when this
happened so right now we're actually
forming an episodic memory we're all
here together we're at this memory event
this is a a certain place and time it's
tagged it's specific to right now so
this becomes a personal autobiographic
memory as well of this event and now
another type of memory is what we call
semantic memory that's our facts about
the world so that's our knowledge our
general knowledge we can Define memory
we can look it up in the dictionary it's
almost the dictionary definitions that's
our semantics but both the semantic and
episodic are also what we call
declarative so I can tell you about it I
can tell you about that event I can tell
you about
you know a fact about memory you know
memory in the hippocampus is a crucial
Center so that's a semantic fact that I
can declare now those things are not
quite as separate as they seem because
tonight we're learning about memory and
maybe for you it might be the first time
but as you learn more about memory it
becomes
free from tonight and that becomes more
of a semantic knowledge fact but these
are all again explicit or what we can
talk about that's contrasted with
implicit memories or what we can learn
as a procedure or a process so learning
to ride a bike you probably I don't know
if you can remember exactly what had
happened but most people when you learn
to ride a bike somehow you just do it
you actually can't tell me exactly how
you learned it or how to do it it's sort
of we know you learned because you no
longer put your feet on the ground
you're not wobbling you're stable and
you're not crashing and perhaps you're
going very fast now so that implicit
memory is different and sometimes when
you try to explain what you're doing you
don't do it as well right because
exactly right and one other type of
memory I guess we should talk about is
the working memory our short-term memory
which is most people think short-term
memory is the thing that you keep for a
few days or a few months or a few years
but it's actually just a few seconds up
to a minute so have a short term or a
working memory you've got to hold the
information like a phone number if I
tell you my phone number Veronica you
can keep rehearsing it till you put it
in your phone and write it down but if
you don't rehearse it or put it
somewhere it disappears so that working
memory is very temporary and it needs
work to keep it up so all those
different memory systems are useful for
different things if you're working at
your grocery bill you're going to do
your working memory or if you're trying
to tally up whether you've got enough
money but if you're um going to qpac for
a memory event then next week you'll
talk about that as an episode it'll be
part of your autobiographic memory and
so do we understand at the level of say
brain physiology or perhaps even right
down to a molecular level
the different kinds of memories
people talk about functional
neuroanatomy or networks now but
actually the neuropsychology when we
work with patients with brain damage we
actually have a very good lesion or
damage in the brain Behavior
relationships so things like the
episodic memory we've all been talking
about the hippocampus and that's
certainly the memory Center for episodes
and the personal memories to encode but
in terms of the semantic memories really
we talk about the anterior temporal
lobes bilaterally so slightly different
area and then our working memory
depending on whether it's for verbal
information like a phone number that you
hear or if you say go to an art gallery
and you look at a nice painting it's a
sketch or a picture so that is very much
in the right hemisphere as opposed to
the auditory verbal what you hear is
more in the left but a different part of
the brain than your personal memories
and the semantic facts and then the
implicit or learning motor skills is
again slightly different so there are
different parts of the brain that
support the different types of memory
and one other thing I just probably
should say is our frontal lobes have a
very big role in encoding being able to
focus your attention to see what is that
information how am I going to get it
into the store or into the via the
hippocampus you know you need to
organize the information perhaps you
need to do things to it in order for the
information to go in well and then to
retrieve it at a later Point again
that's the frontal lobes the left and
the right have different roles but from
an evolutionary perspective the thing
that has always perplexed me a little
bit but again evolution is a random
process so it's not like it was
fine-tuned by some being above to be
optimized but one why do we have to work
so hard to get certain kind of learning
in a certain kind of behaviors into the
place where we don't have to think about
it so we can do it like the riding of
the bike or the playing of the piano I
think so many of us would benefit if the
trajectory from learning to automatic
Recreation of what we were learning was
an easier path why is it so hard
well I I feel like there's two different
types of the memories so the emotion
we've talked about and it's almost
um as if the emotion can almost
short-circuit or or almost trigger so
the emotion changes the internal organ
our internal sense and it almost alerts
the sensory system the perceptual system
to encode the information but the
prefrontal cortex in a way is the top
down more effortful so I feel like
there's a more automatic route to
Memories going in but there's also the
effortful
having to create a strategy having to
focus attention having to do those
things so why do we need that is that
related to the evolution of the frontal
lobe I would say probably yes there's a
lot to be said about experience too
though in optimizing the Brand's ability
to predict what's coming next so they
always say that memory is the path for
the the bridge from the past to the
Future sure so we we get better with
time so so things that are happening
later in life you know it's it's built
on a foundation of experiences that can
then help the brain bypass that slow
learning process you're talking about
and it starts to fill in the blanks
based on the on memory so new learning
is make is a lot more uh facilitated and
if we talk about the D sorry no
obviously that that's one important
point I suppose memory in a sense we're
representing the external World in our
memory and we're creating models of the
external World in our memory and the
world is full of uncertainty so I think
having very cut and dried shortcuts
um Can can lead to
representations of the world that are
very extreme so I think we need to
maintain skepticism
um in in that sense are you saying so a
more gradual process allows more
experiences to contribute and so you
don't get wild swings and thinking the
world is this where that way it kind of
averages out over time that's right I
mean memory Pathways change very slowly
and that certainly has an evolutionary
function because you know Revolution
generally doesn't work slow change works
and it's the same with the knowledge
it's the same with Neuroscience we build
things up very modestly you know we move
from the periphery in we don't make big
leaps in science we we move in slowly
and carefully
so Oliver you know we are all surrounded
by an enormous number of memory storage
devices right we've got hard drives
we've got the thumb drives you know we
walk around with these computers and
phones and so forth there's a more
analog version of storage that I think
comes to mind when we're talking about
memory which is kind of a film strip as
if the way that we sort of store an
event is like these series of still
images that are somehow in our brain
even our opening piece use that metaphor
where we had a projector Illuminating
one still after another in the you know
the sprockets of a film strip are any of
these reasonable metaphors for helping
us to understand how memory actually
does function I mean in one way the film
strip is not too bad because
um encoding our experience so if you're
in this place we have Vision we have
sound we have thoughts happening at the
same time and our brain tries to capture
all of it so initially actually you know
one second afterwards we literally
capture all of it and then as time goes
by
um filtering happens and so we kind of
keep um like skeleton of that event
after a couple of minutes or later and
um if you want to tomorrow remember that
event then our brain will bring back
that you know Skeleton version of that
event and I mean you can already feel
that it's not the real thing because you
can you know if you memorize something
it's not taking over your vision like
putting on VR goggles but it's more like
um you know an unclear image and um but
it's it's really a representation of the
actual event so that if you remember
something the same neurons or subset of
the same neurons would become
reactivated so if you look at the new
picture like a new drawing today and
then remember tomorrow
the neurons that are active from seeing
the picture and remembering the picture
they will overlap and will be less
active by remembering but this will be
maybe 20 of the neurons
um that you get reactivated again so our
visual cortex get active if we remember
something visual our orderary cortex get
activated if we imagine hearing a sound
and for other memories all of that comes
together so in a sentence really just
yeah I'm reactivation of patterns that
have had been active during the actual
experience so here's the thing I I fully
understand
how say a digital camera can capture an
image at least in principle I'm not
getting into the technology of it but
you know the photons are coming in and
the camera itself is able to measure
qualities of the incoming light and
store that and then reproduce it in
order to give us a digital
representation of the image good I
understand that I understand how sound
sound is recorded I understand sound is
a vibration of air and I understand how
vibrations can be encoded even
mathematically and then used to recreate
a version of that sound again but but
here's here's the thing that that
perplexes me a little bit and perhaps
you guys can help me with this
when it comes to the brain we don't only
store the things that you just described
we don't just store the scene we don't
just store the sound we don't distort
the other senses melon touch and so
forth we also store our reaction to that
stimuli
and when it comes to the reaction
there's such an enormous range of human
emotion how does the molecular structure
of this or that molecule in the brain
hold on to that kind of almost
infinitely variable information
can you help me get my brain around that
well I don't think it's actually an
explicit memory but what it is at the
very deepest molecular layer level it's
a the threshold for the way the neurons
will respond in the future so they call
it metaplasticity right so it's a change
that occurs at Deep layers or levels of
of a cell's function which changes its
responsibility okay so when when cells
are neurons are firing in the brain they
it's a coincidence detector where
they'll be at a certain stage of
activity those neurons become integrated
into a new memory but they themselves
then their threshold for future
responsivity it has changed forever
right and then that allows them to be
part of the existing memory and future
Integrations of new information but but
like Verona you you discussed the
hippocampus in your little beautiful
mini discourse as the Memory Maker and
I've also read you describe it as sort
of the memory indexer oh I don't want to
put words in your mouth but I'm pretty
sure should I read that
how does it do that in other words I
totally understand that if you're able
to recreate
similar neural firings to what my brain
is doing right now if you're able to
tomorrow get the same neurons to fire as
they're firing right now I should be
recreating something that's very close
to like you you said Oliver just a
subset because I don't want my arm to
start moving tomorrow and I'm thinking
about tonight I just want to have the
memory without the action and therefore
we want to scale out certain things but
how do molecules how do molecules store
enough information
to elicit those future neural firings in
the right pattern that I can call them
up tomorrow how do they do that well
there are certain neurons that actually
encode the temporal context of
experience so that will fire in sequence
in combination with the population of
cells that are are active at the time of
an explicit memory but did you want me
to explain the molecular basis maybe
maybe just quickly I wouldn't go too far
yeah just this is really just for me you
guys can just think about something else
for a moment if you don't mind no but
yeah take you through the slide or oh
yeah why don't we do that sure
absolutely all right so every time you
know we experience an emotionally
charged event the brain releases uh
neurochemicals neurotransmitters such as
dopamine and serotonin and those
neurotransmitters change the threshold
of responsibility of the neurons and
that establishes new contact between
neurons but what we found in recent
years is that these neurotransmitters
actually
enter the nucleus of the cells of the
neurons in our brain okay and they find
their way in there and then they start
to interact with proteins
in the nucleus of the cell so what
you're seeing here is a picture of
um your DNA okay and the yellow is DNA
wrapped around these core proteins
called histones and we now know that
neurotransmitters that are released
during these emotionally charged events
actually find their way in and interact
with these proteins these core proteins
and it'll be it elicits something called
a Cascade of epigenetic modifications so
that's this is part of the genome that
controls the expression of the genes so
what happens you can see that the DNA is
tightly wrapped around these proteins
under normal situations and then when
they're bombarded with dopamine or
serotonin the DNA relaxes
now it's accessible for Activation and
much like a dimmer switch okay there are
chemical tags that occur on our DNA in
response to learning which allows the
DNA to be turned up or turned down in
the moment but also in priming it for
future responsivity so you can almost
say that your memories are causing a
change at the level of your DNA so
everything from structure changes so we
know about the right hand double helix
that Watson and Crick discovered but
during a learning event the DNA will
flip and it'll go the other way in a
left-handed turn and that makes it more
amenable to modification so just why I
understand so you know the old version
that I think many of us are familiar
with is we think about memories as
synaptic connections right or sort of
the wiring of the brain the hardware
doesn't change in terms of the
ingredients it's just the connections
between them changes are you suggesting
that it's beyond it's more than that
yeah so fundamentally it's still about
the contacts between cells but at a
deeper layer for this whole metaplastic
future priming event to respond in the
future there are changes that occur at
the level of DNA
okay so what happens like a showing
there is there's structure changes in
DNA and it's the DNA of particular
neurons there'll be neurons that are
active at the time of a given experience
right so they can be the same or
different depending on what experience
like they could be overlapping right and
there's different regions of the genome
that are responding as well
um but fundamentally what happens here
and I'll take you through it a little
bit is once that DNA is opened and
primed for Activation reader proteins
come in and start to read off the code
and then it starts to spit out a
molecule that you'll all be aware of now
called RNA and these RNA molecules
there's many different kinds and they
exit the nucleus now that we're coming
back out macro level we're going back
out to the synapse again so these RNA
molecules that have were expressed from
the DNA leave the nucleus travel along
the processes of the cell to the points
of contact between other neurons called
the synaptic compartment and there these
RNA molecules do all kinds of
interesting things to change the way our
cells talk to each other right so you
have a two it's two pronged right so you
have a signal going in changes the DNA
makes it more amenable or responsive the
threshold changes for its reactivity and
then that in turn sends a message out to
establish those contacts between cells
which you we all know of and that leads
to long-term memory so it's both and and
so these rnas they're somewhat different
than from the traditional RNA molecule
that we'd imagine just you know go into
the ribosomes and coding for proteins
these are somehow making the synaptic
connections stronger or yeah well
they're they're called Regulatory rnas
and it turns out that 98 of our genome
actually encodes for these rnas that
don't make a protein
and it's the tip of the iceberg in terms
of our understanding but we're making
Headway in in understanding how certain
classes of RNA that don't make a protein
are actually transactional and they they
process information inside the cell so
they tell different molecules where to
go in this case they tell molecules that
in the synaptic compartment what to do
they're coordinating all these events
and it's pretty interesting when you
think about that that RNA predated
everything even DNA sure RNA was the
first molecule on Earth yeah and now it
has this
um Exquisite role in establishing the
structural context of memory right so
it's like an internal system the brain
keep track so that the process that you
just described you know you don't write
over a previous change if it was a
memory that you want to be stable
presumably you want to go to a different
location for this kind of change you
think every neuron has the opportunity
of more than ten thousand contacts with
other neurons and somehow it keeps track
well let me know you know there's you
know Grandma's you know 89th birthday
leave that alone you go to another part
of that I don't know how I think that's
where the whole idea of recreating
memories comes in like there's yeah I
can't answer that question explicitly
but I can say that in general
experiences change the threshold of
responsibility in neurons and that the
emergent property of that is memory and
so so Oliver let me ask you this you
know if I if I'm going way back you're
remembering something you know when I'm
five years old and and you described it
eloquently in terms of you know you're
you're coming close to a recreation of
the neural firings of the experience
when you're five and that's how you are
having a memory of that time but my
brain now has been undergoing like
Decades of transformation through like
the processes that we're talking about
so it's a different brain today than it
was when I was five so how is the case
that those neural firings that are
mimicking what my brain was doing
decades ago still yields the same kind
of memory in a different brain
I mean I guess it's um it's um careful
process of Maintenance So that obviously
the cellular change over in the body
um would not change the information
content and
um
so therefore I mean I think the changes
or the threat of change is actually more
coming from experience or I'm not using
information so that the brain again the
idea of trying to be efficient would
update information would kind of
downgrade information and to therefore
our interaction is probably a bigger
threat from that perspective even though
obviously it would typically act in our
favor then just the typical cellular
renewal process that takes place but
would typically leave information intact
because you know for the same reasons
it's you know Suddenly It's not that
important functions of our brain stop
working you know because of the
changeover and and therefore the same
would apply to the memory mechanisms as
well
and and can we segue from that to
retrieval right so you're you know
that's how memories are formed and again
anybody jump in on this how well do we
understand the retrieval process you
know at say you know a physiological
level but also a molecular level
I mean it depends on which level you
look at because like looking at the
molecular level is very different than
you know working with patients or doing
neuroimaging so from my perspective
mostly coming from your Imaging is
looking at pattern completion so that
typically retrieval happens if you get a
partial input that reactivates the
complete memory and that partial input
can be something from outside like the
smell aside a word that can reactivate
the complete memory or it could be
internally generated that if you want to
remember something then essentially we
generate a retrieval key which then also
will just activate that isn't that sort
of circular when it comes to the
internal version it almost feels like to
generate the memory I've got to have the
memory in order to stimulate the memory
so where does it where does it come from
one solution to the problem is that our
memory is always active to some varying
degrees and some parts of a memory are
more active than others so it's just you
look at it as a network with different
levels of activity so therefore there's
always something active and we can
therefore nudge it more in One Direction
that leads to more activity in that area
which then leads to it eventually
becoming conscious so lots of our memory
are just kind of potentially retrievable
but not in our Consciousness but um
um and only a small aspect of it is
currently
um obviously there are some there are
some ideas that there's active
inhibition so your memories are already
always online and ready to go but
they're being actively inhibited so this
neurotransmitter called Gaba that's
critical for that process and if you
relief the break turn down Gaba then it
can promote the retrieval of memory and
then there's other ideas that it's even
electrical based signaling
what I would say between what what
you're saying
um you know the molecular level is
infinitely complex
so if you multiply what you're saying 10
by 68 billion multiplied by 15
000 dendrites potentially per neuron you
have this system of fabulous complexity
and that's pervasively connected so you
can it it's you know it's dizzyingly
complex so you can you can approach it
from any of the levels that we're taking
it from and you can this it's a
never-ending story and the other thing
about memory is it's it's uh the brain
is a circuit
and not only is the brain a circuit but
the brain and the body is a circuit as
well and if we're talking about memory
and emotion and I suppose you know I'm
basically a medic
I you know I think a lot of the time we
forget about the body when we're talking
about the brain but remember emotions
there they are experienced in our body
they may be made in the brain but
they're actually experienced within our
bodies so you you can you can take
memory from the level of the Madeleine
from the level of touching somebody's
finger up to the level of trying to
understand
um RNA transactional Concepts and it's
it's all memory it's it's it's what
makes us human I think ultimately that's
a good point about the body and the
Brain connection so that in cases of
traumatic memory like PTSD there's this
massive Drive of the periphery right
which causes problems with being able to
retrieve memories so some forms of
treatment for PTSD actually Target the
peripheral system so they give
Propranolol which is a beta blocker
people used to use it for high blood
pressure or folks with Stage Fright
right so they would suppress the
physiological
well I'm afraid of you
so suppress the body's response which
then promotes the cognitive
function so it's intimately connected
and so Gail you you you in your practice
you you've you've dealt with the
extremes of of of memory and just just
to get into it you know there's um a
wonderful story I'm sure many people are
familiar with it boar has wrote the
story about a character funes who could
not forget anything at all and at first
sight that sounds like something that
many of us would sign up for right I
mean you know when you when you forget
important moments in your life there's a
sense in which they feel gone almost and
yet in this story this fictional story
it doesn't turn out so well for the
character because when you're not able
to forget anything at least in the hands
of Borges the character couldn't
generalize everything was so specific
every event was distinct there was no
category of events that allowed a
coherent Narrative of life to to to
actually be written so what's your
experience with patients I gather there
aren't many but some who can't forget
that's right they're out many and I have
worked with both extremes those that
have lost all their memories as well as
those that can't forget so we're really
talking uh about highly Superior
autobiographical memory and actually I
think Rebecca is here the only person in
Australia who actually has that
phenomena but this is something where
memories are just coming and and arising
constantly many memories so it becomes
intrusive and we're not talking about
memories like 911 or you know big events
that we all remember we're talking about
what did you have for breakfast what day
is it what was the weather like you know
what what
um happened during the day you know did
you walk down the road so these are
memories for everyday mundane events
that just keep getting stored and stored
and stored so the specifics as you say
just keep adding up so it's almost like
a filing cabinet that is full of every
day of your life now some people can do
that from say middle childhood or early
teen
Rebecca actually goes you know quite a
long way back so her her mind is
constantly giving these memories or
bringing them forward and at what level
of resolution and again if I'm probing
in a way that somehow is no
inappropriate but I mean is it like what
happened at you know 6 36 p.m on Tuesday
or is it more it can be that specific I
mean obviously certain things would
stand out more so you know if it's a
family event or a birthday but it's
really it's personal memory so when it's
related to your personal events so it's
not just memories for information in the
news on the day so it really is about
what you did so for Rebecca it is what
she did on a a daily basis and we've
tested that out experimentally going
back looking at different dates and
asking questions and probing that in
different ways and it's actually
phenomenal just how much information
there is now it comes at a cost you know
the cost is the intrusion so she doesn't
sleep very well or that's a bit of a
problem you've almost got to actively
preoccupy your mind in order to be able
to get to sleep otherwise it's just
constantly having memories or different
thoughts keep coming so and it is it
limited to experience I mean for
instance
um can uh I feel funny uh can Rebecca
like remember the digits of pi you know
is is it that only if that's of Interest
so she can actually remember every line
every bit of the Harry Potter novels so
the seven Harry Potter novels because
she's interested
we actually compared so what she could
do with people who also said they were
Harry Potter aficionados so we didn't
just pick anybody like me I haven't read
all the books but we certainly looked at
other people that had that interest but
it's different so so it was quite
effortful to learn those but in fact
it's it's
um that information is actually what we
call semantic memory but she has
personal memories around learning those
books and and have you do you understand
I mean I mean is the brain structure
that yields this capacity different from
well no so structurally we've actually
done some very fancy Imaging where we
just looked at every structure related
to memory so the hippocampus the
amygdala the prefrontal cortex the
temporal lobes every structure when we
compare to sort of a normal data set
they're all
like the same size so it's not like
there's a massive hippocampus sitting in
her brain it's not because of that so
you know one idea is that it is just the
connections um possibly stronger but we
haven't actually we haven't got that
evidence and in fact worldwide there
isn't really strong evidence that that's
the case and how many individuals
worldwide do we know of with that
capacity I think there's somewhere
between 60 to 100 now there was about 60
there's probably more at this point and
and this fellow who I remember them
Solomon sharashevsky do you know that
name who studied by luria in the Soviet
Union yeah there's a whole on this so
it's slightly different so that that
case actually
um used mnemonics so had some tricks and
also had more of a photographic memory
so there's some little differences but
it's it has some similarity you know one
of the things that really struck me when
we were
um doing some tasks is I showed Rebecca
this black and white scene of a beach
now I've used this all the time we
elicit spontaneous speech and clinical
practice it takes about a minute well
I've shown lots of people and they've
never mentioned colors or sounds but
when Rebecca looked at this scene she
was describing the The Sounds the smells
the colors well this is a black and
white scene so the richness of which she
is encoding that so the taste the smell
so there's a lot of extra information
available she assigns to the experience
that that's right so that she ascribed
to that whereas I have never heard
anybody else do that so it makes me
wonder whether actually that information
is available to all of us but maybe we
are filtering it out so in some sense
there's no filter so the details and the
rich richness are coming in and being
retained whereas you and I were probably
comes in it goes away it just um sort of
flows through right so Oliver I'm just
wondering so Tim described the
possibility that memories are kind of
always there they're just suppressed if
we inhibited him and and now this is an
example where the memories are always
there and they're not suppressed
um which which can have positive and
negative impacts as you're describing so
what is the role of of suppressing or
forgetting memories is there an
evolutionary utility to that I would say
twofold I mean first of all saving
energy in terms of maintaining or
building those memories and you know the
brain consumes 20 roughly of our energy
needs that's a good reason but also to
ensure functionality so that you know
especially evolutionary speaking often
we had to make quick decisions and we
still have you know crossing a road and
all that so we have to filter out a lot
of information incoming information
about a lot of our mnemonic information
as well just to be able to react
appropriately because this yeah always
everything comes with the cost and
absolutely and like if you park your car
yesterday you need to remember it when
you park your car but today if it was
yesterday I don't want to know so it's
just taking up space right so some
things you want to but if you forget it
that's my question if you forget where
you parked your car yesterday has it
really been erased or has it just been
suppressed and it's still there I would
argue you probably didn't encode it in
the first place so when you parked your
car and walked into the shopping mall
what were you thinking about where the
shop you were going to were you thinking
about what you're doing next or were you
actually focused on what you were doing
in the moment well Alva you've actually
done studies on the relationship between
location and and memory so you have
insight into this
um yeah I mean one aspect also I think
the interference is the other one so
that especially with like the parking
examples a few everyday park in the same
general area but somewhat often in a
different spot that and that's this
issue of like overlapping memories and
our brains trying to be efficient and
not store you know 10 000 entries of
where we park our car but trying to keep
the the most relevant and that sometimes
might go wrong because maybe we have
paid more attention yesterday than we
kind of did today so that system is not
error error free but overall it would be
still typically calibrated for you know
the best efficiency in our day-to-day
life
and of course one thing that we all fear
is the the exact opposite you know as as
we get older and as we're living longer
so many of us experience parents or
loved ones who go the other direction
they begin to to lose memory so is there
any insight that we gain from the
extreme where one can't forget in order
to deal with the extreme where one can't
remember well I mean I think it's partly
related to training and and what can you
do to maintain or to maximize your
memory right now so this richness of
encoding the absolute the attention that
goes on that you know that's something
that from midlife or even earlier life
we can be almost working on or being
aware of making it conscious so there
are practices things like mindfulness
things like the meditation attention
training strategy training so all of
those cognitive skills that you can sort
of boost and put in top-notch condition
I guess you would say right from well
middle middle age like I thought earlier
if you can those are good skills to do
you know whenever someone says to me
I've always you know I lose my keys I
lose this I always think what were you
thinking about when you did it and they
are always thinking about something else
so their mind in a sense is wandered off
so there's those basic things that we
can all do to help just keep our focus
and our attention being deliberate and
that's the the prefrontal cortex also
that top-down control of just our
cognitive abilities our thinking skills
I think we all think it's out of our
control and it is to a degree there's
the biology sure but there's certainly a
lot of things minimizing the stress so
that we don't shrink our hippocampi you
know all those little things really add
up and you want to keep your in a sense
your thinking skills in good condition
it's like you exercise to keep your body
in good condition you can also do
training and exercises to help the
thinking it's interesting because it
seems like the cost of of experience
across the lifespan is this the wicked
cost is that it leads you to be on
autopilot and you become less attentive
to new learning events
so over time our experience which is
meant to optimize our ability to predict
the future based on our memories
actually works against us
because then we stop paying attention as
much because we're on autopilot exactly
that kind of integrates into the aging
process automatic versus the you know
the automatic processing versus the
active and I call it the active thinking
or active thought
yeah yeah I suppose I I'm
I think you could look at it in a
slightly different way
um I'm not sure they're working against
each other and in a sense I think the we
don't need to pay as much attention to
things
as we gain more experience
and I think that's you know you see that
particularly in professions where a lot
of knowledge is based is experience
based rather than book based
and you know an older professional if I
was asked to go to a younger or an older
doctor I go to the older doctor
because I want them to
I want them to understand at an abstract
level of what's happening to me I want
them to be quick I don't want them to do
100 tests I don't want their attention
on every detail that doesn't require
that attention what I want is them to be
able to filter through it all and focus
on the issues that are important and I
think we with memory we we tend to be
very focused on Executive function on
speed on attention but there's there is
an awful lot of abstract information and
that accumulates over the years and
that's hugely important in terms of not
you know in terms of us individually as
we age but also in terms of society that
older wisdom
um
it really doesn't need to be part of the
way we live together collectively but do
you think that that would have an impact
on the processes of memory updating
right so every time we there's a theory
that every time we recall information
the brain changes its state to enable
the updating of new information right
reconsoleration yeah so that could also
be impacted in the aging process as well
right that's right so that there's a
kind of a gray zone of what's being
updated and what new information is able
to come in because of the executive
attentional processing that so no so no
doubt that that's explains what I
started with with my memory of being
very young and and I see it as a
third-party Observer so I've somehow in
the reconsolidation process have changed
have changed that memory so so to what
extent are our memories as we get older
just sort of manufactured using the
input of the memory of an earlier stage
of Life are we simply telling ourselves
made up stories that have some semblance
of Truth corroborated by others yeah
right exactly so like I I don't know if
one can quantify it but what fraction of
my memories are are real and what
fraction of them have I just fiddled
with over the past decades for one
reason or another
well I think there is a reconstruction
so you know you almost reconfigure every
time you pull the memory out of the
drawer yeah you know it it depends if
you pull it out now then this situation
is going to influence and in a sense
combine with that memory so next time if
I if I'm sitting on the beach then
that's actually going to interject so
there is a level of construction is is
one of the words that's thrown around
now where you reconstruct and put it
together based on your thought processes
at the moment so there is a combination
or a recombining of details in a new way
and they feel just as real
yes and maybe again I don't want to get
all meta here but maybe they are real I
mean the real to me as an individual
even though they don't have a direct
basis in a past experience
well and it may have a seed of a basis
in a passage yes exactly so so in in
some sense it's almost like the tree
growing it's the same tree but it's now
got a lot more hanging off it I think it
it's very individual as well like how
much some people have very strong images
or or memories for word for word you
know I have a niece who almost can word
for word regurgitate entire
conversations she's been doing that
since she was about five so her auditory
memory is fantastic so that's very
different from somebody else so we all
have strengths in what Remains the core
but then different details come together
in a different way
so given that given that we all do that
throughout our entire lives
is there
a chance that in the not too distant
future we'll be able to do that
volitionally
to be able to do something like you know
Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind I
mean get into the brain well maybe
you're talking about future thinking
because that's also something now where
people people really say that if you're
constructing your past memories in fact
it helps us it's very adaptive in
helping us to imagine the future so it's
the same sort of process so this is
quite helpful if I want to imagine if I
did this and then I did that you know
and I'm planning to do something in the
future then I can actually work out what
the consequences are and then make a
choice will I do that or not so I think
the memory in talking about this in
terms of the past actually can help us
think about how do we train or teach
people to in a sense have more of a
metacognition about future well that's a
very useful obviously important role of
memory to god future Behavior but I I'm
thinking about something a little bit it
more intrusive right which is you know
we began by talking about trauma and its
role in creating memory one can imagine
that there are evolutionary util
usefulness to be able to respond to that
because if that gun is in your face at a
future time you now have experience with
that and that allows you perhaps to deal
with that situation with greater
efficacy than you would if it was the
first time that you encountered it good
absolutely on the other hand their
downsides certainly of having those
traumatic memories
can we learn ways to suppress those and
is that perhaps a way forward normally
we talk about something you don't want
to suppress you want to talk it out you
want to work it through and sometimes
that works for many people for some
people it doesn't but what if we could
go in there and excise that well there's
a memory there is a pretty significant
literature on the idea that
um when memories are retrieved they're
subject to modification and that's being
kind of harnessed as an explicit therapy
for people with phobias or PTSD so when
they retrieve that that fear response or
that memory there's an intervention that
could be applied right they back in the
50s they used ECT so electroconvulsive
therapy which caused Amnesia of the
event that was recalled at that moment
in time and then later on in
pre-clinical studies folks have been
using something called protein synthesis
inhibitors
at the time of retrieval right so when
the memory is in that labile State they
can intervene and erase the memory that
was reactivated and how effective is
that and it's now we're moving into this
I mentioned Propranolol that is one
therapeutic approach to helping folks
with PTSD and phobia to help them
suppress those um invasive memories and
is that viewed as a in the clinical
world is that viewed as a promising way
of going forward well well I think first
of all the the initial point you made is
very important that it's not always good
to talk and it's not always good to
ventilate and it's not always good to
re-traumatize somebody by reopening
those Pathways in a very Vivid way and
sometimes it's more appropriate
particularly in situations of a more
severe trauma
to to try and forget
um and certainly in my work
I've seen people who've had psychotic
experiences that are really quite
horrifying
um I think it's very difficult for us to
imagine psychotic experiences unless we
have been psychotic ourselves I mean
essentially what you're you're you're
hearing voices the way you are hearing
me now so they're not voices in your
head
as is commonly thought there are voices
out there and if there's nobody there
well then somebody there may be hidden
speakers in the wall there may be
extraterrestrials from Mars that are
listening in but somehow we can't see so
all sorts of bizarre and dark and
sometimes grotesque worlds are
attributed by what are usually nasty
auditory hallucinations
and in situations like that certainly it
would be untherapeutic to try and do
anything other than tell that try and
explain to the person that their brain
was firing off and that they were having
all these experiences that they're not
based in reality and that they're better
off coming into the shared what I call
the shared reality that we're all lucky
enough if we are lucky enough to be able
to share in you're all hearing my voice
you're not hearing some other voice
that's trying to talk over mine so
you're not confused you're in the world
you're in the moment you're in the
shared Consciousness that we're all a
part of so certainly in situations like
that I I think it's counter therapeutic
to to go into therapy to delve in to
investigate those experiences and then
if we come back to just thinking about
the memory of that you're strengthening
it you know by going I'm back you're
you're actually adding to it and it
becomes almost stronger yeah
um and in some some situations I think
Tim you're probably referring to phobias
so in that sense sometimes you can
change the association with the memory
and that's based on some of the the
different pavlovian type learning so you
can actually weaken that or strengthen
something else to it so you can meddle
with memories in that sense which can be
harmful and helpful to ride the old ones
and that's the clinical decision making
as to when do you do that when do you
not yeah so one one final area in the
remaining time that just want to spend a
a little time on asking you about
I think many of us think of our personal
identity
as being bound up with our memories or
maybe even being our memories it's
almost as if I am the collection of of
my memories that is who I am right
that's what distinguishes me from others
in your you know clinical work and
research work
do you come to a more nuanced version of
that or a solidified version that that
really is what we are as human beings
long collections of memories that
summarize our experience as a living
system on planet Earth
Oliver I mean I guess we can look at
identity from two sides from the outside
I mean obviously even if we lose our
memory the people surrounding us still
have memories of us so but yeah I think
from our personal point of view in terms
of who we think we are memories would be
crucial and I can that would make sense
given that we forget a lot of
information that was our our sense of
identity is somewhat changing you know
when we age
um yeah and the more information you
would have about our childhood I guess
that would enrich or um our identity so
I think yes definitely
intimately linked memories of ourself
and yeah and you know I immediately
think of a patient I worked with
um I was working in London at the time
Sheena McDonald she was quite a public
figure and she had a severe brain injury
from a from being run over by a police
fan and she actually made a documentary
who am I now if I don't have my memory
it was really the whole premise of that
and she really felt that her identity
was affected she had quite severe well
she was in a coma and then she had
post-traumatic Amnesia which was a stage
where she wasn't laying down new
memories for about six weeks and then it
was about six months that she had patchy
memories but she struggled and she
repeatedly came back to that question
and that made me change my view and
really think about our identity and when
you lose that memory you maybe feel the
same but she was asking am I really the
same or do I just think I am and I guess
for all of us I don't know as I get
older I certainly feel that
um
I I think that some of the details or
the detailed memories disappear a little
bit but I don't feel that that's changed
my identity as if there's some essential
core yeah that's you and the memory is
somehow wrap around that but if the
memories go the core still is process
but if you if you don't have a frame of
reference of people that recognize you
and you recognize them even if they're
telling you things about yourself that
you would have once known then you don't
you you don't have a sense of who you
are right without that recognition of
the person yeah in front of you right
yes so there's a sense that you know my
identity is tied to the group who is
around me and and how do you relate to
me you know partly that's where group
and Social Psychology comes in where the
identity is formed in relation to others
or in relation to what you think I am or
what you even have a room and you didn't
recognize anyone any every time you
walked into the room it would be very
um disturbing I think your foundation
would be unstable right
yeah I think I think we're coming back
again and again to the whole issue of
connectivity
and I mean we all live in a moment of
Consciousness so our memory and the past
exists in the present and it is in the
conscious moment of the present that we
predict the future as well
and I think that the human you know the
human race is is very like like memory
we're living in a current situation but
we have a high level of awareness of
of the past and we're trying to prevent
past mistakes in our future behavior and
I think we are evolving as a species in
the same way that we evolve and develop
personally so so memory binds us
together it was like the coming back to
the to the 911 we all watched the same
clip visually again and again and again
and that that Consolidated that memory
that is a collective memory that we will
always share and that will always be
with us and we're not going to get a New
York confused with Chicago in that
memory because that's a very solid core
memory and also the pizza is quite
different
but yeah nice
yeah so I I think
it's about connection and I I really
think as you get older that's one of the
wonderful things about not being young
and being older is is that your sense of
connection with the world I think
expands so that the big the big
Collective memory that is the human race
and the human project that we're all a
part of we're all a part of a collective
memory we're all a part of of that
project and yes Jean-Paul satra said you
know we we make a narrative and then we
recreate it and we recreated constantly
and
um Alice Monroe said something very
similar
um in the last decade so we are evolving
but memory is important because we learn
from that in in the journey in terms of
moving forward
and and so as we we look to the Future
one can imagine that the rapid
increase in our technological facility
will allow for an interface between the
biological and the technological
do you do you envision that there will
be a time that human memory is not just
a collection of molecules in this Gloppy
three pound squishy gray structure that
sits in this bony cave perched on our
shoulders but rather we're able to hook
up to other devices that can assist us
so that you know we don't have to have
this worry about losing memories or
suppressing Memories We just sort of put
them off to the external cert you know
and then we bring it back whenever we
want is that science fiction or is that
something that you think is potentially
going to happen I feel in many ways
we're already offloading our memory in
what sense using iPhones and devices as
our guides right with us as the
intermediary at the moment but we don't
have to worry about phone numbers
anymore we don't have to worry about how
to drive or where to drive our car we're
not reading Maps anymore yeah let me
just you're right but but are they not
more than me Mystic aspects of memory
they're like the non-human parts of
memory and I'm very happy that my
children don't have to learn times
tables anymore a London taxi driver
would speak otherwise that's right they
used to be incredible yeah but now right
I know but I still think that there
there is human memory and human memory
is
is part of the human condition and a
machine will never mimic that that in my
books
I mean in some ways you're talking about
you know the semantic memory we can
offload yeah and and these personal
autobiographical the things that are
essentially relevant and personal that
that is the human bit too and that's
also those memories which we don't have
to pay um lots of effort to encode we
were talked earlier about it how hard it
is to memorize but it typically only
pertains to information that
um you might not have an interest in so
once you develop an interest then it's
not difficult anymore and So like um
Harry Potter books there example like
everybody who's a Harry Potter fan would
have no problem memorizing the story you
know reads it once and can answer the
questions but it's much harder with the
times table and um and therefore um yeah
like the social memory you know social
relationship those aspects that aspects
that um kind of coming or maybe we lean
on technology a bit more and then it
frees up creativity yeah that's right
positive way of putting it down and so
you you know we began this conversation
like one of the initial questions I
asked was you know how is it possible
that molecules can store the the the
feeling of a warm breeze on the ocean or
or the sensation of you know a birthday
cake when you're six years old but
underlying that specific question which
has to do with memory is the Allied
question of Consciousness right how is
it possible that matter can yield mind
how is it possible that matter can yield
these inner worlds of sensation of which
memory of course is an integral part but
you know there's the whole world inside
of our heads does does your work on
memory
make you feel that you're getting closer
to an answer to that question as to what
is consciousness and do you think that
it is simply physical or do you think
it's something beyond the physical
I think Oliver gives us a sense of the
complexity of the processes involved and
that just um in how much more complex
the processes would be to I guess fully
understand and explain processes like
Consciousness and um and what do you
think is is it simply matter creating
Consciousness or is it something else
I mean it would be hard to save a
certainty because I guess we're not
there yet to kind of you know pinpoint
it with certainty so oh come on save us
some some certainty
well I'm hoping for surprises yeah well
I don't think there's something out
there if that's the question you're
asking well is there something beyond
the molecules I I think I don't think
that there is but many people disagree
with it I would have thought that you
would say that there there is my guess
would have been that you would have
thought that there is but am I wrong
you're absolutely wrong okay
no consciousness is a multi-layered
thing yes and at the outer reaches of
Consciousness we are looking at
ourselves and that is why we have a
feeling as if there is something out
there I agree with you but that is the
ultimate in Consciousness and and that's
that feeling that there is
well I I like when you bring in
different levels of complexity so energy
matter you know what does it give rise
to is there something that is it all
just within me I I think energy extends
Beyond I think it's partly in the
relationship in the relationship with
different things so I think that the
energy is actually quite key in all of
that so I don't think which is in the
molecules which is in the little levels
it's in the bigger levels so I'm
probably more on the I think there are
some metaphysical or some things that
are bigger than what we can imagine
right now I think it's a little bit too
reductionist to say it's the little
molecules running around and that's it
now I noticed the expression on your
face when you said reduction like that
oh you know you know for me it'd be it's
reductionism you know you know is it
just sort of a difference I I I guess
you know I am very interested in
creativity and creative thought how do
you generate new ideas so for me I feel
like I don't want to reduce down to the
littlest level of molecule I like the
complexity of when things come together
synergistically and make something
Beyond what's actually just there so I I
don't know whether that's a physical
Beyond what's there or whether I'm
saying it's an energy Beyond what's
there but I think that there's more yeah
so the only thing that I would say to
that and then I'll I'll leave it to him
to take us out I don't consider that we
are reducing things through reductionism
even though the words sound so similar
have the same root rather I think it's
utterly remarkable that these
ingredients called atoms and molecules
can somehow come together in complex
ways and yield
the creative impulse and the creative
output I mean how remarkable is it that
molecules can look at themselves and
wonder about how those molecules are
doing what they're doing
I agree we're on the same page then okay
in that sense
your view Tim oh well I mean I have a
lot a lot of things to say about that
but well let me tell you you have a
negative one minute and 22 seconds to do
it so we've got we've got DNA it's a
four base code right computers are made
of ones and zeros so already we have a
device that's inside of us that has a
computational
memory storage of getting it's a
quadratic Improvement right and then on
top of that four bases in each of the
four bases can be chemically modified in
four or five different ways which again
offers an opportunity for an incredible
amount of storage yes
memory but but but is that
a full description do you think of
what's Happening inside of our heads or
or not I suspect you think that it is
but I don't think the words because I
got the wrong ones no no I'd like to
think that there's the capacity for a
great amount of storage in at the level
of our DNA so I can break it down to the
most reductionist right level we could
talk about fermians another day right
right
well well that you know that's a anyone
want to give a final remark before we
wrap it up or um yeah so this has been
absolutely fascinating conversation on
mind memory Consciousness trauma emotion
and the swirl of all these ingredients
that yield the structure that we call
the human being so I want to thank you
for human beings for joining us here
tonight for this discussion please thank
our group
[Music]
thank you